The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Today is a very big day for all
of you.
Your first semester at MIT is
half over.
And, in addition to that,
you have a lot of challenges
remaining ahead of you for the
rest of this semester.
I am going to help make the
chemical challenges fun for you.
That is what I am here to do.
I love chemistry.
I love teaching 5.112.
This is the best part of my
week.
So, here we are.
Do you guys know that chemistry
can be incredibly fun?
Let me just show you how fun
chemistry can be.
And that is just the gravy.
The fun part is actually making
the molecules.
Any of you see this picture in
U.S.A.
Today recently?
Not reading that important
journal, I see.
Well, this picture did appear
very recently in U.S.A.
Today in a story that talked
about the recent Nobel Prize in
chemistry that was awarded to
Professor Richard R.
Schrock, of our department.
And, in fact,
I don't know if you realize
this, but Professor Schrock was
the first person ever awarded
the Nobel Prize in Chemistry at
MIT for work conducted while at
MIT.
That is a pretty amazing
accomplishment because we have
so many tremendous chemists on
the faculty here,
and he is the first one to
break through in that manner.
And maybe you are here at a
very special time,
and we will see a number more
of these in the next few years.
May with you contributing,
so much the better because you
are here.
And let me just explain
something, too.
Chemistry is fun.
And only on very rare occasions
like this would Professor
Schrock be drinking champagne at
8:30 in the morning,
when this picture was taken.
The Reuters reporter,
Brian, who took this photo,
is actually a pretty good
friend of Professor Nocera here.
And so he rode over from the
Schrock household.
And Dick and Dan came in
together in the same car,
as they often do,
from Winchester on that
morning, which was a very
exciting day.
If you come to see me for
office hours maybe I will tell
you more about it in detail,
but it was an exciting day.
And I am in here,
too.
My name is Kit Cummins.
Kit is my nickname.
My name is Christopher.
You can call me Christopher or
Kit, or you can call me
Professor Cummins,
or you can just say hey,
chemistry guy.
That will be fine.
I am in this picture primarily
because it is part of being in
the right place at the right
time, just like I am here now in
front of you.
But also I am in it because we
three are three in one of the
areas in our department that
really focus our research on
inorganic chemistry.
And what is inorganic
chemistry?
I will say more about this
during the semester.
But inorganic chemistry is
really the chemistry of the
elements of the Periodic Table
inclusively.
So, a pretty broad topic.
And I like doing chemistry with
lots of elements.
And so that is why these guys
and I share an association with
each other.
And, in fact,
I was a graduate student with
Professor Schrock.
And I am very,
very proud to be able to say
that.
Hopefully, my computer will be
staying on, here.
And I want to point out,
too, that people who love
science want to know something
about its history.
And part of all of that is
knowing the academic family from
which you derive,
depending on the person you've
studied with in learning about
chemistry.
And I studied with Schrock.
And Schrock studied with
Osborn, a fantastic chemist in
his own right,
no longer alive,
sadly, to see his progeny,
Professor Schrock,
win the Nobel Prize.
And Osborn studied with
Wilkinson, and Wilkinson was
also a Nobel Prize winner.
So, you do not have to go very
far back in that lineage to
encounter that recognition,
the Nobel Prize,
Schrock, and then it skipped
Osborne, and if you go back to
Wilkinson, there is another one.
And you can keep going back.
And I am not going to go
through that whole history today
because I have another history
that I am going to need to go
through with you today.
And I am going to bring this
back over so it does not
distract you.
And this other history that I
need to impart to you today has
to do with some of the
contributions of Gilbert Newton
Lewis.
This is one of the most famous
of all chemists ever.
And if you like chemistry,
I encourage you to think of the
word Newton, as it is found
engraved in one of the pillars
in Killian Court at MIT as the
middle name of Gilbert Newton
Lewis.
It is conceivable that having
that middle name weighed heavily
upon Gilbert during his
lifetime.
But it remains a good moniker.
And in the future,
when you have kids,
I encourage you to consider
using it as a middle name.
It worked well in this
particular case.
When you get the notes for
today, which incidentally will
be available on the website
after class today,
so you don't need to write down
everything I am writing down.
You are actually going to get a
little bit more in the online
version than what I am writing
down here.
And if you find that you forgot
something that I said during
class, just email me.
I will tell you what I said.
It is not a problem.
But if you want to write down
notes while I am speaking just
to make notes that you can refer
to later to refresh your memory,
that is fine.
I think your taking in
information in lots of different
ways.
We are going to use the
computer and we are going to use
the blackboard today.
And you are going to have
available stuff from the
Internet a little bit later,
too.
And all of that is good.
I think you should try to
reinforce and not worry if some
of the information is a little
redundant.
And never be afraid to ask
questions, especially,
I like to take questions by
email or if you come knock on my
office door.
In 1916, Gilbert Lewis
published a landmark paper in
chemistry in the journal of the
American Chemical Society which
remains the flagship journal of
the American Chemical Society.
And this paper was entitled
"The Atom and the Molecule."
Besides being an incredibly
important and influential paper
in the history of chemistry,
"The Atom and the Molecule" was
also the basis for --
Like I said,
besides being a hugely
influential manuscript,
"The Atom and the Molecule"
also laid the foundations for
Lewis's thinking about
electronic structure theory that
shaped the way we still today
talk about valence and chemical
bonding.
So, an incredibly important
paper from 1916.
In the lecture notes today,
you will find the specific
volume and page number for that
reference in the journal of the
American Chemical Society.
And I encourage you in your
copious free time to download
that paper.
It is really great.
All the American Chemical
Society journal articles are
available, from the very
beginning.
And you can download it and
read it.
And, having had this
introduction today,
I think it will probably prove
to be a very fascinating
exercise for you,
if you choose to do so.
It also was the basis of a book
that Gilbert Newton Lewis later
wrote on valance and on atoms
and molecules.
That is also a classic in
chemistry.
And, should you be shopping for
chemistry books on e-bay or
something, you might find a rare
copy of it.
And if you do and choose not to
buy it, please alert me and I
will buy it.
But Gilbert Newton Lewis,
"The Atom and the Molecule."
In this paper you are going to
see, if you do choose to
download it, that he was
thinking about polarity.
And he was also thinking about
the relationship between the
polarity of a molecule relates
to the polarity of a substance.
And I mean, when I say a
polarity of a substance,
that that would be a sample,
you could say a water molecule
down here and liquid water up
here.
And you will see this kind of
sigmoidal graph that Lewis made
in thinking about how polar
condensed phase substances were
as compared with the structure
of the molecules that comprise
the substance.
Down here, in this region,
you will find that there are
substances that are not terribly
polar.
And what I have written here is
the organic shorthand for the
hexane molecule.
Liquid hexane is an alkane,
akin to methane,
which is natural gas.
And so, if you are not familiar
with this way of writing organic
molecules, I will just tell you
briefly that this terminus is CH
three or a methyl group,
and then it is CH two,
CH two, CH two,
CH two, and then CH three,
another methyl group.
So, that is some
organic shorthand.
And I will go through that kind
of shorthand occasionally so
that you become familiar with
it.
And that is the hexane
molecule, a very non-polar
molecule composed of elements,
carbon and hydrogen,
that have very similar
electronegativity.
And then he goes on up the
curve here, and you find this
familiar molecule,
benzene, considered next,
as being somehow more polar
than hexane, and liquid benzene
accordingly in its solvating
properties in the condensed
phase, being a more polar
medium, as it were.
And then, as we continue
progress up this scale,
he writes next molecules like
the diethyl ether molecule.
No doubt you are familiar with
ether and its applications as an
anesthetic.
The first use of ether as an
anesthesia in an operation in
medicine was carried out just
across the river in Boston.
There is this historical Ether
Dome there that you can go and
look at.
But, nonetheless,
we are just getting up a little
bit more polar than benzene.
And then next you find
molecules like this one.
That contains an organic
functional group called an
ester.
That is ethyl acetate,
which is a substance that you
might have smelled if you ever
built models,
because some of the glues that
you may have used would contain
it, or the paints.
And so, it is a system that,
in terms of its molecular
structure, is more polar.
And, when you use it in the
condensed phase,
it behaves in a manner that you
would describe as more polar.
And then, finally,
you get up to some very polar
systems, like the water
molecule.
Like the ammonia molecule.
And, finally,
Lewis talks about a species
like this, which is sodium twice
sulfur.
That is actually called sodium
sulfide.
And it is a salt analogous to
table salt, sodium chloride.
And being a salt,
it is obviously very polar
because there is quite a large
degree of charge separation
between the atoms in the
molecule.
And, accordingly,
if you take that salt and heat
it up until you have got it as
hot as its melting point and
make it liquid,
that molten salt has
individually charged ions moving
around in solution.
And that provides a very polar
medium, which would be excellent
at dissolving polar things.
You will notice here that on
the non-polar side we have
elements, carbon and hydrogen,
that are very close to each
other in electronegativity.
And then, as we examine this
relationship,
we start putting in elements
like oxygen or nitrogen,
which are very electronegative
close to the upper right-hand
side of the Periodic Table.
That introduces polarity both
in the molecule and in
substances comprised of the
molecule.
And then all the way over to
the involved atoms,
sodium and sulfur are very
different in electronegativity
and, therefore,
have very strongly separated
charges.
And, in thinking about this,
Lewis proposed the notion of a
continuum.
And his musing on this are
really quite lucid in that
paper, but the idea was that a
molecule, or a part of a
molecule even,
you can analyze molecules in
terms of smaller pieces of them
that can be identified within
the larger molecule,
can lie on either side of a
continuum in reference to a
number of different properties.
And the section of class that
we are launching into today
deals with acid-base properties.
Let's mention that first,
acid and base.
These are two ends of a
continuum.
But he also recognized that you
could have a molecule that would
be an oxidant.
And the counterpart to that is
a reductant.
And then, here is a term that
maybe those of you who have
studied organic chemistry in
more detail than most would
recognize.
This is electrophile.
Electrophile has a counterpart
called a nucleophile.
And then, the fourth one that I
would like to mention is
acceptor.
And, of course,
the counterpart to that is
donor.
Please remember those four
pairs because when you can
understand and make predictions
about those four properties as a
function of molecular structure,
then you will be a chemist.
I mean that is a large part of
what it is all about,
understanding all the different
chemical properties that will
make it interested in terms of
acid-base, oxidant-reductant,
electrophile-nucleophile,
and acceptor and donor.
And the currency of chemistry
can be seen, with reference to
this, to be the electron.
That is what chemistry is all
about.
And so, we will be talking a
lot about atoms and molecules
with reference to their
properties and how the
properties stem from knowing
something about the electrons in
the molecule.
And I think you are going to
find this to be quite fun.
With respect to the properties
of the medium,
let's talk about a substance
like hydrogen chloride.
This is just to illustrate what
I was saying over there.
If you take a molecule like
hydrogen chloride,
and it is a gas,
of course.
And if you make a solution of
it in hexane,
hexane is going to be our
solvent, and then what you find
is that in this low polarity
medium hexane solution,
liquid hexane,
the HCl molecule remains intact
and floats around in solution,
interacting weakly with hexane
molecules that surround it.
But if you take this HCl
molecule and put it into a
solvent like water,
then something on the other end
of the continuum transpires
because we get ionization to
produce hydrogen ions.
And they go off and are
separated in solution from
chloride ions.
And we will talk more about
just what is going on when you
separate H plus from Cl
minus and let them
diffuse apart in aqueous
solution.
But you can see,
I think, the dichotomy.
Either the proton shares in the
electrons of the chloride,
or it just pops off and ionizes
and goes out into solution.
And Lewis wanted to understand
this.
And, to understand it,
he developed a theory.
And his theory was the "cube
theory." In this part we get to
draw some cubes.
And he decided that if you
thought of the nucleus,
which he calls the kernel,
of an atom as being located at
the center of the system,
then if you had an atom like
neon, which is a noble gas with
eight valance electrons,
that these valance electrons
would want to get away from each
other as far as possible because
they repel each other.
They are all negatively
charged.
This could be,
here, the neon atom.
Here, on that cube,
is how he would represent the
electronic structure of the neon
atom, with the eight electrons
here represented by
peach-colored circles,
each the vertex of a cube.
So, they got far away from each
other.
And you can see that in the
historical archives,
some of his original sketch
books containing these ideas are
there, and now you will know
what they mean.
You will see that he progressed
beyond understanding the atom to
understanding the molecule.
And here is one of the
molecules that he talks about.
Here we have a molecule
containing 14 valance electrons,
all arranged in that manner.
And this could be,
for example,
the I two molecule.
And let me draw it in terms of
a dot structure,
--
-- like that.
And there was known at the
time, partly because of the
contributions of Lewis himself,
something called the Rule of
Eight.
And that was a reference to
this notion that most atoms want
to have eight electrons in their
valance shell,
and it is also something that
we call today the Octet Rule.
So, when you see the Rule of
Eight mentioned in his paper,
it is the familiar Octet Rule.
And you can see here that one
of the key features is two
electrons shared equally.
And when electrons are shared
equally like that,
you have a molecule with
symmetrical charge distribution,
charge referring to the
electrons where they are in
space.
And then, he showed that you
could think about this another
way.
You could consider some kind of
a geometric distortion of the I
two molecule, like this.
Distorted, not only because of
my drawing, but because of the
way the atoms themselves are
thought to be rearranging in
this process.
Notice that what has happened
here is that the I two
molecule is doing something
electronically such that one
iodine is starting to pull away
from the other.
This one over here is carrying
with it the electron that came
from over here.
And, in that case,
what we have is a molecule in
which we are developing partial
negative charge on the
right-hand side and partial
positive charge on the left-hand
side.
As I was talking up here,
I was thinking about what I was
going to say here,
because the ideal is that
molecules, even if they are
inherently non-polar like the I
two molecule,
in their equilibrium structure
they can have electron
fluctuations that lead to
partial charges in the manner
shown here.
And Lewis was working
beautifully toward the
development of a theory like
this that would allow the
description of electronic
structure to be made graphically
apparent.
And this is something that
chemists really like to do,
is we like to be able to see
stuff.
I hope I am going to be able to
show you some really cool stuff
this semester.
And, in fact,
even some really cool stuff
before we finish here today.
So, that is the development of
charge as represented using the
Lewis cube theory in an I two
molecule.
Next, one thing you could do is
say, let's just continue this
process, and the right-hand
iodine with its eight electrons
pops off.
That would give you an ionized
situation in which you had an I
minus floating away from
an I plus molecule.
And that situation is drawn in
the notes, and because I am
running out of space on this
board I am not going to draw
that one up.
Instead I am going to go onto
another triumph of the Lewis
cube theory, which was its
ability to explain different
chemical bond orders.
By the way, Lewis never got the
Nobel Prize.
He certainly should have.
A dramatic oversight.
He was born in Massachusetts.
He was a Harvard professor for
a while and did not like it,
and came to MIT to be a
professor for a while.
And, although he liked that,
that was not far enough away
from Harvard,
so he went to Berkeley,
where he became the department
head and was very successful
over a long period of time in
learning about chemistry and in
teaching chemistry.
I will invite you,
and you will see this in the
notes, too, to go ahead and see
if you can find a good biography
of Lewis because it is very
instructive.
Anyway, here is another
molecule considered by Lewis's
cube theory.
How many electrons are being
shared by the two nuclei or
atoms involved?
Four electrons shared.
We can circle them here.
That is four electrons shared.
Therefore, that is not a single
bond.
We call that a double bond.
And so, that might be a
representation of,
for example,
the O two molecule.
Here we have I two,
here we have distorted I two
with charges developing,
and here we have O two.
O two is a very
interesting diatomic molecule.
We are going to talk about that
later in the semester,
but for now let's just leave it
at that.
But then, even though this was
quite a successful theory,
the cube theory,
it has certain problems,
certain shortcomings,
such as, we can do single bonds
with it quite well,
and now we can do double bonds
with the cube theory,
but what do you do if you have
to make a triple bond?
That was a problem for Lewis.
That should be a problem for
you, too.
Cubes just don't fit together
that way.
They have edges and faces,
and that is it.
And they have vertices.
You can do one vertex.
So, triple bond is a problem.
And we know that there are
molecules that have triple
bonds.
And we cannot handle them with
the cube theory,
so we are going to have to
something a little different,
for that reason.
But there is also another
reason that had to do with just
considering the chemistry of
light elements like hydrogen and
helium.
Those elements tend to
associate themselves with only
two electrons.
And so, Lewis decided,
well, maybe the rule of two is
more fundamental than the rule
of eight, and that we should be
thinking about pairs of
electrons somehow.
Because he looked at what was
known about chemistry and
realized that in most molecules,
the number of electrons is
always even, is always divisible
by two.
That is something interesting
about two electrons at a time
being important.
You take that together with the
triple bond problem,
and Lewis started thinking in
terms of electron pairs,
and this is where this
"electron pair theory" comes
from.
Although he spent a lot of time
on the cube theory,
he was perfectly willing to
cast that theory aside in favor
of something that maybe was
going to work a little better,
the electron pair theory.
And how does that look?
Well, of course,
his initial pictures still had
the cube, which just shows that
once the human mind fixes on
something, it fixes on it with
great tenacity and it can be
hard to shake your way of
thinking about things.
But hopefully you will be able
to do that.
He still decided,
let's arrange these electron
pairs on a cube with the nucleus
of the atom supposed to be at
the center, and let's keep these
electrons, now,
nicely collected in pairs.
And let's get these pairs as
far away from each other as
possible, for the same reasons
we used to be putting eight
electrons as far away from each
other as possible,
namely, electron repulsion.
Now, the problem of electron
repulsion between the pairs was
not really solved.
And Lewis decided that the pair
theory worked so well that he
was not going to worry about
that, and so we won't worry
about it yet,
either.
You have your four pairs of
electrons arranged at the center
of four of the edges of the
cube, and that geometry is what
we call a tetrahedron,
which I am drawing the edges of
here in pink.
You have a tetrahedral
disposition of four pairs of
electrons, now,
for an atom.
This might again be the neon
atom.
But the nice thing about this
choice is that if you want to
you can make single bonds with
this theory, and you can make
double bonds --
-- with this theory,
like that.
And then, due to the properties
of the tetrahedron,
you can also make triple bonds.
This is marvelous.
You can see that the famous
chemist Gilbert Newton Lewis was
talking about electronic
structure in terms of
symmetrical things,
like tetrahedra and cubes,
as a way of arranging electrons
reasonably in space.
This could, again,
be our iodine molecule.
This could be,
now, our O two molecule.
And, if we continue that
progression in the Periodic
Table, what is this molecule?
Dinitrogen, N two,
the major component of our
atmosphere, another interesting
molecule that we will be talking
about as the semester progresses
forward.
But chemical language and
electronic structure theory are
very much still permeated with
this affection for symmetry and
the problems that you can solve
using symmetry to analyze
electronic structure theory.
Let's talk next about another
molecule because we want to talk
about Lewis's development of the
electron pair theory,
but also we want to understand
how that relates to acid-base
properties.
And so, let me draw here
another molecule.
And when you look at this
molecule, which is the aluminum
trichloride molecule,
in which I am drawing out
explicitly all of the electrons,
not forgetting these two.
And having drawn the aluminum
trichloride molecule
and looked at it like that,
you can ask yourself is the
number of electrons divisible by
eight?
Yes it is.
We have a 24 valance electron
system here.
It is divisible by eight.
Of course, it is also divisible
by two.
You can also ask yourself is
this molecule,
as written, one that satisfies
the rule of eight for all four
of the atoms?
No.
We have a problem there because
this thing is electron
deficient.
And if you were Lewis,
you would want to know,
well, if it is electron
deficient, this molecule must be
doing something about that to
get more electrons.
Which atom is missing
electrons, here?
The aluminum.
How can we give aluminum more
electrons, in a structure like
this?
Can we get it up to the rule of
eight?
Double bonds,
awesome.
Beautiful.
We can make a double bond.
And, if we do that,
we can allow aluminum to
satisfy the rule of eight,
or allow the rule of eight to
satisfy aluminum.
Whichever way you want to look
at it.
And see what we have done,
here?
We have taken one of the
electron pairs,
say, this one,
and we have moved it in between
the aluminum and the chlorine,
so it joins the other one in
there.
And we get a double bond.
And now, everybody has an
octet.
But what is the problem with
that?
The problem with that is that
chlorine is very
electronegative,
and it does not want its
electrons stolen away by the
very electropositive aluminum
center.
There are other ways that
aluminum can ultimately satisfy
its octet, and this is how we
get into the realm of "Lewis
acid-base theory."
And I want to show you one of
the other ways that aluminum can
satisfy its octet,
and then, we are going to move
to the computer so we can
visualize some of these
properties.
If I put my aluminum here --
and do you remember this
molecule up here,
the ammonia molecule?
I am going to say that if I
draw that ammonia molecule in
place, here --
The ammonia molecule comes in,
and it has its eight electrons.
It is sharing six of them with
three hydrogens.
The idea is that it has an
extra pair of electrons on that
nitrogen in the ammonia
molecule, that it can share with
the aluminum.
And now we go ahead and
complete the picture.
And we can have eight electrons
around everybody.
And so the rule of eight is now
satisfied for the three
chlorines, for the aluminum,
and for the nitrogen of the
ammonia molecule.
The ammonia molecule is what we
call a "Lewis base."
And the aluminum trichloride
molecule is what we
call a "Lewis acid,"
for reasons that should now be
quite clear.
And I want to show you how we
can look at these things.
And if you will give me just a
second here, I am going to load
the aluminum trichloride
molecule up onto the screen.
What we are going to do is
remember that there are lots of
different ways in which you can
visualize molecules.
And I want to show you some of
the more interesting ways.
All that is is a picture of the
aluminum trichloride
molecule with spheres drawn at
kind of arbitrary radii.
The size of these spheres is
not representative of any
particular physical quantity,
but we can change that.
And so now, what we are going
to do is draw the thing a
slightly different way.
And what you can see is that
the positions of those nuclei
are in this flat box.
I made the box kind of flat.
It is kind of a slab because
this AlCl three
molecule is conveniently kind of
flat in its structure.
And what are we going to do
now?
We are going to draw a contour
surface.
And I like this.
We are going to use the solid
surface method,
first.
And can you see that now?
These curves that enclose the
four nuclei of the aluminum
trichloride molecule
do have some physical
significance,
because what I have done here
is taken results,
in this case from the quantum
chemistry calculation,
but you could also take it from
an X-ray crystallographic
structure determination study.
And I have drawn a
three-dimensional contour map.
The value of the electron
density at every point on the
surface of one of those ovaloid
shapes is the same.
Just like when you have a
contour map to describe in two
dimensions an interesting
complicated surface,
we can do this in three
dimensions as well.
And one of the things you
notice, when you look at a
surface like this,
is that the value of the
electron density actually goes
down to some low value in
between the nuclei,
for this.
When you see molecules
represented as balls and sticks,
or if you represent molecules
this way, just showing a pair of
dots between the aluminum and
chloride, you may not be getting
a physically complete picture of
the situation.
You can get a much more
complete picture if you have
access to the actual electron
density.
And then, you can even go a
little further,
and I want to show you
something very cool.
First I am going to need to
load in a second molecule.
And that will be the product of
the first "Lewis acid-base
reaction" that we have
discussed.
Because, I didn't say it over
there, but that was your first
exposure to a Lewis acid-base
reaction, in which the ammonia
molecule comes in and binds to
the aluminum trichloride
molecule,
in order to satisfy the valence
requirements of the respective
atom types.
And so, here we are going to
look at that molecule,
and we are going to look at its
electron density.
And I think you are going to
like this very much.
Here it comes.
And then I am going to
represent this as a solid
surface.
The value of the electron
density everywhere on this
surface is 0.1 electron density
units.
I want you to start thinking
about how that shape appears
there because I am going to
underscore that a little bit
more in just a second.
But one thing you should notice
is that at the NH three
molecule, which is pictured at
the top of that representation,
what you are seeing is that the
value of the electron density
does not get very small as you
go between the nitrogen and
hydrogen nuclei because both
nitrogen and hydrogen are quite
similar in electronegativity as
compared with the aluminum atom
in this system.
The fascinating thing about
illustrating a molecule in this
way is that we can actually
associate another property with
the color on the surface.
Now what we are doing is
looking at the aluminum
trichloride ammonia system.
And let me see if I can make
this thing gradually spin,
so that I can talk about it
without being pinned to my
computer.
What we have on the surface on
each of these electron density
isosurface enclosed regions is a
color that corresponds with a
value of a function that tells
us about the propensity of
electrons to be paired at that
point in space.
The Lewis theory is now colored
onto the electron density
isosurface of this Lewis acid,
Lewis base complex molecule.
And the values that correspond
to those regions in space where
electrons are most likely to be
found paired up are colored
blue.
Where they are least likely to
be found paired up are colored
kind of red-orange,
here.
And then an intermediate color
is this green.
And so, you can see that you
have electron pairs associated
with each of the three NH bonds,
up at the top.
You have another electron pair
here in blue,
which is very proximate to this
aluminum center,
that is very electron deficient
as we had found right over here
because it lacks an octet.
And then, each of these
chlorines is able to attract
electron pairs.
Because chlorine is very
electronegative,
it attracts the electron pairs
to itself and sort of withholds
them from the aluminum center,
but yet, that development of
charge separation keeps
everything together in what we
can call an ionic interaction,
an electrostatic interaction.
You can see here covalent
bonding, donor-acceptor complex
formation, and electrostatic
contributions to bonding.
And all of this is just an
illustration of the brilliant
ideas of Gilbert Newton Lewis.